are you working on well I'm working on
my greatest creation I promise you'll
see it when you're a little older okay
okay have you ever wanted a secret
identity thing one of yours on how do I
look
oh my god your internet famous looks
like the second best thing to being
actually famous I'm Jenn Jenn this is
exactly the artist that Starlight has
been looking for it with a little help
of course ladies and gentlemen the
internet sensation who is Jim we're
getting reports that's the number one
trending topic on Twitter there are some
voices that are too special to keep
hidden cuz of your father's words so
there we were headed towards the unknown
and this is where it gets weird face
said your dad's inventions didn't work
where you go from here that's up to you
is this like a solo contract it's
exciting I mean back smile and most
important look like you're having fun
but don't really have fun got it let me
explain what's been going on explain
what you want to go solo that's my whole
family's supposed to act the version of
me that they want doesn't exist you're
under contract the concerts going as
planned all right - let's see what
you're trying to tell me time with
family with the ones you love most
there's nothing more valuable than that
even the odds seem impossible you need
to trust the people you're closest to
fix us
showtimes energy
in my heart you'll always be my jam
Avenue desertion snitched atrophy
noticed I'm even label name